Hi, I'm here with Kaushik,
who's one of the co-founders of Locket.
And Kaushik, I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about how you iterate quickly
and how do you do user testing to make
sure that you have a good product?
>> Oh sure.
So, once we come up with
the product feature or
something which we want to build and
try testing it out on our user base.
We quickly list out
all the action items.
And then, we talk to all the people
who are very close to us, and
see what their feedback is.
And then,
we iteratively build on top of it.
We start off from a very, very small
feature addition to current app,
or we build a very small MVP.
And then, we test the technology from
users, get their feedback, try to track
their metrics and see if it is going
in the positive direction or no.
If it is going in the positive
direction, then we take it up,
improve it, or we remove all
the features which are not doing good.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
that way we iterate a couple of times
to get to a place where we can release
an test it out.
>> Yeah, and you talked a little
bit about how you'll contact maybe
friends or people in your network.
Are there any other specific users that
you'll make sure to go after to make
sure you're hitting
different demographics, or
maybe particular people who
have certain phones, or?
>> Well, it totally depends
on the kind of application.
For example,
if you are releasing an application for
students then we mainly look at
the kind of phones they are using.
And the main, like what kind of
apps they are already using.
And based on their, interest for
the UI, as well as based
on their utilization ways.
We come up with the features and
organize it in such a way
that it will appeal to them.
And we also make sure that
the UI is very animated and
very focused to that
particular demographic.
For example, if you are targeting
mid 40s or something,
we don't really need to make it
really colorful and very animated.
But if we are talking to
someone like 14 or 15,
then we want to keep it really
engaging and really interesting.
So, based on all these features,
we come up with a list of things.
Which we try to get people into
the workplace and see how they use it or
how they respond to that.
And from there on, build on top of it.